bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france comment avez vous
accueilli ce prolongement du confinement
qui avait été avancée on s'en doutait un
peu
quant à les recevoir a vu que
les indicateurs
n'étaient pas favorables pour une
reprise de l'activité normale du pays
dès la semaine prochaine
c'est une mesure qui est redouté par la
population
ou alors ils la comprennent au vu de la
situation sanitaire
du moins le programme qui a surtout du
mans la population je pense qu'elle
comprend maintenant comme le haut
commissaire a pu le dire moi hier encore
beaucoup de déplacements
pour des motifs qui sont pas forcément
légitime donc aujourd'hui à beaucoup de
professions pour lesquelles on a dû
fermer les entreprises
qui
pour lesquels aujourd'hui ils ont plus
de chiffre d'affaires et qui
souhaiteraient pouvoir le
travailler normalement comme
c'était le cas il ya plus de deux
semaines justement vous parlez de
dominique son rang le haut commissaire
de la république en polynésie française
il a il a annoncé que le nombre de cas
se stabilise mais qu'il reste à un
niveau d'une extrême gravité comment
vous l'expliquez
appelé
comme il a pu et des tee shirts chaîne
c'est un étang il y a eu des éléments
qui a favorisé le développement de khost
qui nous emmenait à cette situation
maintenant aujourd'hui avec le
confinement ont subi qui est en quelque
sorte un confinement des partiels
les gens continuent à
pour ceux qui travaillent à aller
travailler
tue moi sur nous on attend on est à
venir pour dire qu'il fallait peut-être
de mettre en place un confinement
1 un peu plus strictes pour que l'on
puisse ajouter la
ville
d'istres
ce serait quoi en confinement plus
strictement
le même jour de confinement peut maillot
mois de mars l'un des stades et laisser
les entreprises qui sont vitales pour
la vie plutôt que de laisser tout le
monde allait travailler je te dis il
faut savoir pro polliniser les écoles
sont fermées par contre on demande aux
enseignants d'aller
dans les écoles et à cet instant
certains lycées collèges il ya des
réunions qui sont à 70 80 personnes donc
si on veut vraiment éradiquer la
présence du gardien d'état dans nos
usines il faut avoir des
comportements qui relève du bon sens
éviter tout ce qui est
l'assemblement même au sein même des
établissements et des entreprises au
niveau de la population vous avez
l'impression que les habitants n'ont pas
pris conscience de
l'ampleur de cette crise sanitaire
je pense que c'est le messager d allah
faut pas compris parce que il ya toute
une polémique au niveau de la
vaccination en a beaucoup qui pensent
que la vaccination le fait d'être
vacciné permet de totalement émises et
peut-être pas
d'être contaminés ça c'est une chose et
a pris 6 au niveau local je pense que
les gens
se rendent compte du mois en a on a eu
un pic de décès
1 25 morts qui est la semaine dernière
je pense que là on est dans une
situation inédite à ma connaissance je
n'ai pas souvenir qu'on ait dû
mettre en place des conteneurs
frigorifiques
parce qu'il y avait plus de place à la
mode du mas est une première
donc je pense que la population les
causes d'une partie de la population est
consciente maintenant mais on a des
modalités de déplacement avec
l'attestation dérogatoires qui a chanté
all ages donc on chope les gens ont fait
tissus en fonction de cette autorisation
est celle des locations qui qu'il allait
accorder pour le déplacement merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions mais à
niveau routier je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire territorial du snetaa fo
polynésie merci